if I could describe some of the best
management practices for the former to
adapt their with these different climate
conditions I would number one I would be
looking at which in so phase are we in
you know if we're looking at El Nino and
it's going to be wet and cool we may
have to delay planting wow that ground
to warm up until it dries out enough so
we can get in there and run if it's la
nina and going to be dry obviously we
need to go in there and plant early as
early as possible so that we can go
after our soil moisture as climate does
change we can expect more extreme
weather and we need to grow our crop
according to and anticipate what those
changes may be an example is this with
anticipated climate change we expect our
peanuts growing season to potentially be
warmer and drier and that sets us up for
problems like aflatoxin so what I'm
encouraging growers to do now is to both
repair their practices whether it's
increasing irrigation ability or to
invest in varieties that are going to be
both drought resistant and more tolerant
to or resistant to app epoxy under hot
and dry conditions we're going to make
sure that we recommend those growers
follow some type of water scheduling
program in order to make sure that we
have plenty of irrigation or moisture in
the soil for what the plant needs and so
if we got a non irrigated field and it's
hot and dry all we can do is maintain
what we can handle in other words take
care of any insects that are out there
that we have to take care of disease
that's out there now some of the ways
you can manage insects really well in
Phoenix and is crop rotation and
planting time so crop production is very
important look at your planting methods
and the varieties and do not go too much
peanut after peanuts because then you
have build-up of insect pests especially
soul cast